islam a british doctor working in idlib
syria right now i'm in ajifa hospital
which is located in idlib city and
funded by one nation on average each
patient that we're treating in this
intensive care unit is costing 500
pounds so many children have died
unnecessarily because we doctors don't
have the drugs
and the equipment needed to save them
with your donation you will enable us to
be able to save lives by the permission
of allah i used to struggle reading the
quran daily before you instructed
instructed me to download this app i
never knew that this app would have such
an impact on people's lives you can go
into the description box click the link
for ios and android and build your habit
with the quran right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
bitcoin has crashed
bitcoin is a life support machine
bitcoin is on the verge of death or has
died are you going to die along with it
are you going to join the coma along
with it brothers and sisters who are
watching this if you have invested large
amounts of money or great amounts of
your savings into bitcoin and now it's
crashed and you have crushed with it i
have a reminder for you brother sisters
from the quran and the sunnah everything
that happens happens for a reason one of
the beauties that i love about islam
when i came to islam is that i was aware
where my risk my earnings my things
are not just money things are going to
reach me i knew they were in the hands
of allah and what was going to reach me
was never going to avoid me or go past
me and what was bound to miss me was
never going to reach me and that
contentment not a lot of people have it
yeah and sadly a lot of no muslims have
it sadly muslims don't have this kind of
understanding again allah number two
brothers and sisters we need to
understand something very clearly allah
says in the quran we will send you a
smaller calamity
and you can call it some kind of climate
if you've lost large amounts of money
that this calamity can divert you from
the greater calamity what does that mean
that means that when allah sends you
something which is devastating you
invested all your money you lost it
you're in a situation of you're
depressed anxiety all your dreams have
been shuttered
it might be
that this thing
is going to get you and keep you get you
back on track maybe this money that he
was going to get was going to divert you
was going to divert you from the
remembrance of allah there's a hadith of
the prophet peace be upon him it is
narrated um
it is um graded as weak by shakhal
animal of mercy on him but we derive
some rulings in a nutshell which is the
hadith that says that allah subhanahu wa
will tell them i see his servant and
might realize that money
is going to be the end of him
and that allah withholds that from him
because he realizes that if he gives him
money it's going to be his destruction
and for some people allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala sees
that being poor for them is not good so
allah subhanahu wa tala enriches them
and
allah says oh knowing that knows that
money is not going to be a great fitna
for them al-basri may allah have mercy
said the following
do not resent the calamities that come
and the disasters that occur for perhaps
in something you dislike will be your
salvation and perhaps in something that
you prefer will be your doom and allah
perhaps you dislike something which is
good for you and something uh and like
something which is bad for you allah
knows and you do not know brothers and
sisters allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
telling you something allah subhanahu wa
is trying to make you understand
something if you
have lost large amounts of money you had
plans to live a lavish lifestyle
whatever it may be etc because you think
that this is going to bring you
happiness you know what's happening guys
you are taking the
over the knuckle once again this is the
biggest problem that as human beings we
fall into we think we know what our
happiness lies in and guess what the
thing that we know where do we know it
from the things that we see glamorous
cars glamorous uh houses glamorous women
or glamorous men or whatever it may be
and we think our happiness lies in that
but indeed allah knows maybe not your
happiness your doom lines in that
let's be very honest brother and sister
subhanallah and look there are some
people who have killed themselves over
this
kill themselves man
please brothers and sisters for the sake
of allah let's understand and
acknowledge happiness comes from allah
do not think these worldly affairs will
ever make you happy i have a mortal in
life i expect the least and i make dua
for the best
don't get it twisted if i had the money
if i had it like
allah without permission praise allah i
tried to carry money in my hand not in
my heart before inja helia used to be in
my heart not in my hand now i carry my
hand if it's there it's definitely i
don't care
as long as i have a helal income i can
provide for my family i can pay my rent
i can give my wife
some money to live by whatever it may be
as long as i've got that alhamdulillah
i don't care what anybody says i live in
a one bedroom flat yeah me my wife and
my two kids live in the same in the same
bed in the same bedroom yeah not in the
same bed with the same bedroom my
daughter's bed two doors is bad we're in
the same alhamdulillah i'm so happy you
know why i mentioned this guys to you
because while i i'm not ashamed i'm
happy i don't even have a five bedroom
while i am so happy in my house
alhamdulillah
i am so happy
contentment is from allah subhanahu wa
tala brahmana says says peace is from
allah subhanahu ta'ala that is my motto
in life some people and i'm going to rap
on this have a go at this oh why are you
working at 9 to 5. you know you do high
aspiration my brother if you're working
at 9 to five and you earn a halal income
well that is more beloved allah than
somebody's trying to be an entrepreneur
and wants to make it and even goes down
to haram roots yeah
there is nothing wrong with the 95
don't make people make you feel like
crap there is nothing wrong with a nine
to five
because in the sight of allah you earn
an income is more detained that's all i
have to say and i'm gonna wrap up that
promises inshallah may allah make is
among those now i'm not saying by the
way again if you can make you work your
way up no problem work your way up man
no problem like i said before if i had
the money but i'll be driving a bentley
i'll drive a bentley yes there's nothing
wrong with that but i'm not going to
kill myself over that and it's not my
goal alhamdulillah make our goal and
ambition that you have for bitcoin and
invest in here this that invest in your
hereafter yeah okay invest in jannah
bitcoin can go
gender is just
gains gains gains
nothing but gains
if only we gave that focus to the
hereafter as much as we do in this
hereafter to the level that people want
to take their life take their life
may allah protect us if you're watching
this
do not despair in this this is a
probably a blessing in disguise maybe it
is this that on the day of judgment
going to change you and get close to
allah that you're going to say
alhamdulillah that bitcoin crashed
because when it crashed it was the
reason for me to come to the realization
and i didn't crash with bitcoin
may allah grant every single one of his
channel assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh